كارثه ماساويه تحطم طائره نيباليه
كارثه ماساويه بتحطم طائره واحتراقها في
نيبال المكان الاكثر خطوره للطيران في
العالم
فمن العاصمه كتمندو التي تعتبر بوابه
السفر الاساسيه اقلعت الطائره المنكوبه
الى مدينه بخارى السياحيه وسط نيبال طائره
ذات محركين من طراز اي تي ار 72
تديرها شركه ايتي الجويه نيبليه كانت تقل
72 راكبا من بينهم 15 اجنبيه
وطاقم مكون من اربعه افراد لكن الفاجعه
الكبرى ان 72 شخصا قتلوا جميعا في حادثه
هي الاسوا في نيبال منذ 30 عاما لقد تحطم
الطائرهم الى اشلاء
عناصر الانقاذ يجبون موقع التحكم القريبه
من نهر سيتي الذي يبعد حوالين ميل عن مطار
بوخار الدولي ويحاولون العثور على مزيد من
الجثث
له سجل كارثي في حوادث الطيران لدرجه ان
الاتحاد الاوروبي منذ فتره كان قد اغلق
اجوائه امام كل الشركات الطيران النيباليه
لاسباب مرتبطه بالسلامه الخبراء ارجعوا
سبب تحطم الطائرات في نيبال الى استشهاد
الشركات الطيران المحليه في البلاد
استخدام طائرات قديمه سيئه صيانه بالاضافه
لتضاريس صعبه للغايه ومناخ لا يمكن التنبؤ
به
طبقا لتقرير السلامه لعام 2019 فان تنوع
انماط الطقس في نيبال جنبا الى جمع تضاريس
غير الوديه يجعلان الطيران صعبا ويساهمان
في وقوع الحوادث
دوله نيبال سجلت في اخر اثنتي عشر سنه نحو
13 حادثه سقوط للطائرات وتحطمها وهذا ما
جعل الشركه المسيره في ذيل قائمه شركات
الطيران الاكثر امنا في العالم ففي العام
الماضي لقى 22 شخصا حتفهم عندما تحطم
الطائره على سفح جبل في نيبال كما قتل 49
شخصا ايضا في عام 2018 عندما تحطمت طائره
ركاب كانت قادمه من بنجلاديش لده هبوطها
في العاصمه النيباليه كتماندو والحادثه
الشهيره التي وقعت في مطلع التسعينيات
عندما قتل جميع ركاب طائره تابعه الخطوط
الجويه الباكستانيه
وعددهم 167 شخصا بعد ما اصطدمت الطائره
بتل اثناء محاولتها الهبوط في العاصمه
باليه كتماندو